au secours
ce lundi matin ce quartier de Kiev
s'éveille avec les dégâts des drones
tomber la nuit
les ouvriers de la Poste colmat les
vitres
les habitants qui vivent à côté de la
centrale électrique physique se
remettent à peine de leur frayeur
S
puis une très forte explosion et j'ai vu
un flash à ma fenêtre puis il y a une
deuxième explosion il y avait de la
fumée noire tout le ciel était recouvert
même s'il s'attendait à une possible
attaque les locaux sont sous le choc
personne ne peut s'habituer à ça c'est
l'hiver les gens se retrouvent sans
lumière et sans chauffage des gens
ordinaires et pas des nazis comme Disney
russe
dans ce quartier du centre de Kiev la
plupart des commerçants ont un
générateur cela fait à peu près deux
mois maintenant qu'ils sont habitués aux
coupures de courant aléatoire
on l'a acheté il y a un mois lorsque les
bombardements de masse ont commencé pour
avoir la lumière et des conditions de
travail descente dans le magasin vendeur
en téléphonie mobile au lexandre doit
composer avec une odeur d'essence à
donner le tournis dans son magasin
les coupures de courant après un
bombardement personne ne sait combien de
temps elles peuvent durer
il y a bien un emploi du temps pour les
coupures planifiées mais il y a aussi
les coupures d'urgence là c'est depuis
9h ce matin ça fait déjà 4 heures au
moins grâce à son générateur Alexandre
n'a pas froid dans sa boutique
dehors le thermomètre affiche moins 6
degrés et l'hiver ne fait que commencer